people think is safe to have a job but
if somebody can find you how is that
safe period like you got to be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you I don't believe I should have
to be nice to get somebody to give me
something if my product is good no
matter how I act you will pay for it
like people are posting like bosses and
people approach things like workers a
lot of people don't want to be bosses
because there's so much responsibilities
that come with it
what's that belief nation it's heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Damon - level talent
at something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world I started the
meant to me seriously try to hang on
people who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by spending a little more
time with them some of their mindsets
beliefs way of thinking seep into us to
help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going from one
of the best Damon Dash and how to become
your own boss mentor me Damon
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be the boss the reason why people
take jobs is cuz they got to pay their
bills when you say be a boss to be
independent everybody should be an
entrepreneur it's everyone has an
apartment right you're the boss in your
apartment right no matter what no matter
how little it is if it's whether it's a
big house or a little house that space
right there you're the boss that's what
your business is that's what your life
is you create the space so you can
control it you control your environment
but you have to art detect that you want
to live in the house build it you know
I'm saying am I gonna give it to you but
once you get in that house I don't care
if the President or whoever it is
anyway he walk in my house Obama you
still gotta listen to me in this house
people think it's safe to have a job but
if somebody can find you how is that
safe period like you got to be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you and if they the people like a
fire you don't be owning evil might be
supervisors so then it becomes like
political if there's no politics when
you in the boss is my way or no way
because I believe that you see that at
any point no matter how much you
contribute that whole thing can be taken
away at any particular time right so how
does somebody then go and just make that
shift to the same they're doing for
somebody else do it for yourself right
if you got paid editor edit your own
movie your pay writer write its home
magazine you know it's like the thing is
nobody ever gave me anything no one gave
me real no record deal I had to do it
myself so imagine if I were to waited
for a deal for jay-z did B know jay-z
there be no Kanye there be no Lee
Daniels there be no Kevin Hart there be
no Rachel boy none of that you know I'm
saying none of them any I had to build
all that like no one's gonna hire me to
direct you know I mean no one's gonna
hire me to be the CEO of a company I
made the company I'm the CEO of it
period that's that
rule number two make good products I
don't believe I should have to be nice
to get somebody to give me something if
my product is good no matter how I act
you will pay for it you know that's
another principle that I learned in the
street when people want their drugs
they'll line up they'll get told what to
do they'll be yelled at they'll be
talked to get in the back of the line
I'm only taking 20s don't even come in
here with a
that kind of thing no one's nice today
the drug dealer don't have to be nice
his work gotta be good and that applies
exactly in real business as long as your
work is good people will come when your
work isn't good you have to have
gimmicks right so in the street you got
two four five three dollar bottles and
chicken bags but usually the works not
good right so in this world when you
overcompensate when you don't have good
work you overcompensate with the tension
you start to become like your self
celebrity that's what you leverage so
now your game becomes going outside
being a slave to what everybody else
thinks
and that's another rhythm that I didn't
want to abide by as well like I wasn't
gonna be about that celebrity all I want
to do is be about good product good work
be respectful make an honest living and
work with honest people and all and the
Internet has made it really possible to
do that because again you can make your
product you could promote your product
you could sell your product you collect
the data and have that relationship
directly with your consumer rule number
three be obsessed with your craft how do
you want to make money I don't know this
is what I do right take yourself to five
years where do you want to be in five
years
see the thing about it is to shoot a
movie you need a script right you can't
just freestyle it you can't say I want
to say this or kind of like that you got
to be very direct and then you put all
your energy to what you want you
visualize it and then it has to happen
I'm a filmmaker so I'm gonna make movies
yeah I want to make I mean I've done
that but I want to do it to where I
don't have to worry about a regular job
yeah this is the way I would do it so I
would make as many short films as I can
just so people can start seeing that
you're good I would star in the movie if
I want to be anyone in this short film
like a real artist is someone that's
damn near obsessed with it like a
painter should be painting eight hours a
day but a band should be rehearsing
eight hours a day if you're a
businessman you should be doing your
business eight hours a day so if you're
focused on something and you're doing it
eight hours a day then you're doing it
at a professional level but you got to
know what you focused on and then you
can take things into your own control it
doesn't happen overnight it's not easy
expect pain expect anxiety expect
everything to go wrong and just be cool
breathe easy and then just see it out
because a lot of people start but don't
finish when things don't happen the way
it's never
happen the way you wanted to happen ever
and if it does do not trust it if the
devil rule number four have boss
thoughts what people make me the
underdog it's funny because they don't
understand what the game I'm playing
just cuz I'm not playing your game or
just cuz I'm not moving at the pace you
moving it don't mean I'm wrong you know
I'm saying y'all ready to say when it's
mine and it's never been like what I've
always liked what someone thought of
record via was dull I was like a lady
lady so I don't know any other language
but boss boss you know I'm saying so
when people don't talk in Boston me I'm
really saying you know I'm saying it's a
language it's just a process a voice
it's like like people are posting like
bosses and people approach things like
for this a lot of people don't want to
be bosses because it's so much
responsibilities that come with it you
are saying they stay out of it and I
always say that you understand what I'm
saying
what but boss only can think about it in
force terms so if someone says they want
to get in business some people might say
well I need somebody that give me a job
that's not a forest or a horse's if I'm
getting my four days if I'm gonna get in
business I'm gonna create the business
figure business but I'm not trying to be
hired my approach is always going to be
bossy you know someone that's not used
to being the boss your thought process
ain't boss we don't have lost boss
fluent boss you know say what I'm saying
around here before winning boss and if
you don't talk to me and boss
I'm not celebrating that your boss dog
is like I speak that yeah let's see you
bet Lane
you should tell with somebody else talks
boss just by their approach one thing
and someone that talks boy doesn't speak
any other language boss
rule number five do what you love how do
you say motivated not get burned out I
only do what I love you got to do what
you love you can't get burnt out and I
do get burnt out
you know once I'm in a business and I
don't enjoy it no more that's the thing
I can't it's hard for me to stay in the
business for a long period of time
because the people tend to make me sick
so as soon as I start to get aggravated
you know it's like I'll be on the block
if the block starts to make me mad I go
to another block even if I got the block
click and it's just like I won't
compromise my quality of living
you don't sample like right now what I'm
doing is you know I'm building things
that I could pass to my kids but only
things that I love them and my family so
I love making movies I'll make it movies
I love it I don't think I'm gonna be
burnt out with that a time soon you know
and then also when you're in the
business of making money off other
people that person could make you sick
and you don't want to make money off
them no more so that's the reason why I
try to only make money off myself these
days and also do things that you know my
girl or my wife rocky because she's
inspired and will do that business I'm
like something revolving my children I
like that business but I worked hard to
put myself in that position and rule
number six the last one before a very
special bonus clip is play the game
right there's a lot of people that think
that the only way you can make it
especially in our business the
entertainment industry that you know you
can't be an honorable honest
hard-working person you've got to be
willing to do whatever it takes
regardless of how you compromise your
own ethics to get to wherever it is you
want to get and I've never believed that
and it doesn't sound like you believe it
either
now you know I don't consider that a win
I consider that cheating and I can't
live with myself I don't play the game
right but other people don't like to go
into different cultures and especially
in business it's like yo you gotta win
anyway you can if somebody's slipping
and you don't take advantage of it
you're dishonouring your family like
I've been in cultures like that mmm-hmm
you know we're lying is okay for your
business you know you're suppose
to do that or else you're a sucker so
you know it's just a matter of
perspective and the cloth you're cut
from and you know it's a rougher world
when everyone is cheating and you're
playing the game right you know it's a
tough world but at the end of the day
it's worth it because you know there's
nothing more valuable than your soul
your integrity your freedom you know
just being proud of yourself I just
don't feel like you know when you you
can't call yourself a winner if you're
cheating you know you're a cheater you
know I just how I feel and you might not
get caught in the human form but God
will get you you think I forgot or
whatever the Supreme Being is
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Damon - on how to have a plan but
before that I want to know what did you
learn from this video what are you going
to immediately apply somehow to your
life your business put it down in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
a business plan that about a business
that doesn't exist is a lie because you
can't you can't say like who do your
facts based on because it hasn't
happened yet you can't really determine
who's going by what and how much this
cost sell you can't say I'm gonna make a
million this year this is not gonna last
you know what what I'll do was put
together without it's like a script I'll
put together how we make the goods I'm
gonna market the goods how much this
cost to buy the goods but we have with
my margin and then when I'm gonna sell
it and then how much I'm gonna put back
into the business and I'm not someone
put in my fire you know is that kind of
thing you know I write things that like
if you look look going on put that on
the wall right there right if you see
you see the piece of paper or that one
that's I got to do you know I like to
put things on the wall I can even know
what I've got to do I need to look at it
and it cross it up I don't consider that
a business plan per se or but I have a
plan
you know I'm saying like I have a plan
plus you want other people to understand
the plan because you can't do anything
on your own so you want to be able to
articulate it to them the way they
understand and that they can look back
at because I've talked quick and like
you said a lot of times I say you like I
didn't understand that
until a year later you know so you want
to have something someone can keep
looking at and they can see you crossing
it off and then they can kind of get it
by absorbing all you know by watching
what you're doing if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it won't you believe it you act like I
have Tulsa what a wail out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad all the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access